I am going to show you the cycle the
mechanism of how the mind virus spreads
through people like Tucker Carlson this
is I really hope that this is
instructive for people okay this was a
cycle that took place over the last week
or so
um an article was written in Newsweek by
a student okay an individual named Kevin
bass wrote an article in Newsweek which
got a bunch of attention called it's
time for the scientific Community to
admit we were wrong about covid and it
cost lives and as you can see
uh uh the title for Kevin bass is Ms MD
PhD student medical school and he wrote
an article where he says as a medical
student and researcher I saw staunchly
supported efforts when it came to covid
but then he comes to say we were wrong
we were wrong about everything now this
is an opinion piece by somebody who is
not really strictly speaking an
authority on any of this stuff we're
talking about a student here and
students know things okay no disrespect
to students but the idea that this is
some kind of medical Authority is of
course very very wrong the fact that
this article was written
got Kevin bass an interview on Tucker
Carlson the next day or a few days later
the fact that he was on Tucker then
makes it seem as if this guy really is a
medical professional rather than just a
guy with an opinion in Newsweek and of
course when something appears on Tucker
Carlson even though Tucker's show is an
opinion show then it is repeated
elsewhere as if it is news and very
often the next day Fox and Friends will
say as discussed by Tucker Carlson
yesterday and this is how you take
nothing you take an opinion article by a
student who's not a medical Authority a
Newsweek and turn it into what seems
like wow it's a report that we were
wrong about covid so let's take a look
at a little bit of this interview with
uh Tucker and Kevin best
thank you for coming on and thank you
for writing this piece which I thank you
I want to recommend everyone totally
non-political again I don't even know
what your politics are I assume you're
liberal but you're honest in this piece
why were you moved to write this this
man is not a doctor or a scientist or a
nurse or a health care worker he's never
seen a patient
he's a he's a student Tucker Carlson has
a student on a show to talk about an
editorial that he wrote
let's hear some of his words shall we
this is by the way from the uh Twitter
account decoding Fox News which is a
really good account
many of the reasons that you discussed
that I realized that we have lost trust
in this country as a healthcare industry
from the the ordinary person uh anybody
who knows anybody who's watching the
media anybody who is on social media and
is talking to Ordinary People realizes
just how angry so many Ordinary People
are and I thought who the heck is an
ordinary person
if you're not a healthcare worker you're
just a student you're calling other
people ordinary I'm a little confused
here I thought that if I wrote a piece
like this apologizing for
you know I didn't set policy but I
certainly supported it and every single
day I certainly added all my friends on
the back for supporting it and for for
for thinking the right kinds of thoughts
I dude
you're just a dude who wrote an opinion
piece
that's it you've never
seen a doctor I thought if I apologized
then at least I was doing my part uh to
to to make things better and what an
attention grab I mean genuinely what an
attention grab this nonsense is and if
you look at the article again this is
just a guy with some opinions he talks
about how he believes scientific
expertise wasn't used appropriately how
a lot of things were preferences and not
really science it became a team sport
there were obfuscations about aerosol
spread and transmission and mass
mandates and all these different things
and he is ready to admit it and of
course that is ripe it is ripe for a
propagandist like Tucker Carlson to say
this sounds great for our show come on
in come on in and explain yourself and
the Fox News viewer doesn't really know
any better medical researcher oh wow
we're talking about a student who is not
a medical Authority in any way who just
said in an opinion piece I used to think
things that I believe were wrong
that's all it is not substantively
relevant to anything but this is exactly
the type of propaganda that many Fox
News viewers see and go oh you know what
it's true The Masks don't work and the
vaccine doesn't work and it never made
sense to stay home and this thing
doesn't spread and it's not a
respiratory virus and it came from a
Chinese lab and all these different
things whereas not only is this guy not
even saying that he's not even someone
with any actual uh medical authority to
be making these claims and this is how
they create a feedback loop we've seen
it in so many other ways the Fox News
opinion side gives an opinion it is then
reported on by the news side as if it is
newsworthy that such an opinion was
given here we're just adding an
additional layer a guy writes an opinion
opinion show Tucker Carlson invites the
guy as if he's an authority to give that
opinion
and then it spreads even further as if
it is now news that this guy said we got
a bunch of stuff wrong about covet now
were there things that as we got more
information our views changed of course
were there things where the facts
changed over time
of course early the first vaccine was
very effective at preventing
transmission against the original
variant of covid over time that
effectiveness at preventing transmission
dropped to what I most recently
understand to be essentially no
protection the idea being that the
vaccine is very effective at reducing
serious illness hospitalization and
death so as the facts changed what I
made an effort to report to you based on
those facts also changed but it was
never about my opinions this is just
opinion this is how Fox News turns it
into quote news reporting